people are dramatic about their lives
but you really did have to raise
yourself
your father and mother were just not
there for you and i thought about this
britney spears documentary
i have so much empathy towards so many
people paris hilton came on the show
and you know she had been
institutionalized by her mom
and you know you think like britney and
paris and
i've thought it for myself i'm sure that
people look on
and think these party girls these
privileges
how dare they have feelings about
any of this they've put themselves out
out there
they've asked for this it's fair [ __ ]
game
and i just go they're humans they're
just humans
you mentioned paris hilton was on your
show the other day and she
said something about that she was locked
up and thrown into isolation
and you said oh yeah i know what that's
like
my mom put me in a place that was like a
full
psychiatric ward i used to laugh at
those like malibu
30-day places they talk about things
that pissed me off
um i was just like a little spa vacation
for 30 days like in malibu was
sort of the opposite of the experience i
had i was in a place for a year and a
half called van i psychiatric
and you couldn't mess around in there
and if you did you would get thrown
either in the padded room or get put in
stretcher restraints and tied up
why were you so bad that you had to go
in the padded room
i grew up you know with like the go-go's
and wendio williams and blondie and all
these like
badass chicks and i just sort of would
like
you know channel my inner riot girl
and i you know some days it was really
funny i would rile up all the girls and
i'd be like
listen [ __ ] this place these people
don't care about you
let's [ __ ] show them all right
everybody i would totally
rile the entire joint up and
it was like half a kid's facility and
half like an
old person's place so like the as i was
like
riling up these like young girls like
the woman and the walker would go by it
was
hilarious how old were you 13
and i was there for a year and a half
don't you think
if your mother had been more equipped if
she had just sat you down and said drew
why are you so angry what's wrong you
know i think she
created a monster and she didn't know
what to do with the monster
and this was her last gasp and i really
was
out of control and i forgive her for
making this choice she probably felt
like she had
nowhere to turn and i'm sure she lived
with a lot of guilt
for years about creating the monster but
then i think she lived in a lot of pain
that i also wouldn't talk to her for a
long time
are you talking to her now yeah we
texted this morning
wow no kidding yep good lord really glad
there is healing there and we have spent
our whole lives
trying to figure things out i said to my
own daughter
you know she was like something came up
and i said i'm not
your friend i'll never be your friend
i'm your mother
and i had a mother who was a friend and
we're not going to do that
i have so much more empathy now to being
46 and a mother of two girls
it's hard and i raise my girls so
much more traditionally and quietly and
very protectively and
it's such an antithesis to my upbringing
but i can't have her feel
bad anymore i'm sure she's already beat
the crap out of herself
for having a daughter who wouldn't speak
to her i mean the pain that i went
through from that
i felt so guilty denying my mom
access to me it felt like i was cutting
off the source of life
right it was as hard of a feeling as
i've ever experienced
definitely the worst pain i've ever
known and i just thought
i have to let this go like what is this
doing for either of us
i think she's old enough now to be
in a different place in her life and i
know
the changes that i've made and how long
they took
i know that's possible for people so why
not her too